welcome to this video playing Thomas
Tallis mm-hmm or not at sea yeah I
suffered the rating hit recently played
a pretty bad live stream session who had
lost a couple of points and I also had a
couple of games that that are not
uploaded because I simply made this very
stupid mistake of somehow not turning on
the sound recording so I record it for
more than one hour which it was without
sound and I figured that those games
yeah uploading those games is kind of
pointless so um yeah I have to fight my
way back above 2,300 and I'm slightly
above it but yeah getting a little bit
higher would be would be cute okay let's
see cute is the wrong word right would
be would be nice to do okay so we have a
pretty weird kind of vitoria tech here
at some very uncommon way wait to play
with 93 and so on I think it was
recently tried by Dimitri under 18 if
i'm not mistaken against them what's
this a geek I aachen I think I aachen
maybe I can play 94 here but that's 96
check so I can I can wait with one move
forward move with this idea yeah yeah I
thought Nyjah for should be should be
good right about he has Queen f4
is Queen F 494 Bishop is seven queen is
seven Queen f4 this isn't this is a as
an annoying resource not tonight before
now that's not looking good okay now
that means i should have considered this
a little bit a little bit more with more
care let's say yeah why does better now
after cancelling long I will play b5
getting tried to get counter play it's
some difficult to do without group d 8
can I go rook the 845 maybe that is
possible actually let me try this before
i'm starting to give up pawns with with
be five for no reason maybe a move like
night be 5 194 as some is better for
white now
EF f 5 4 p-6 I can also go where maybe
b6 Bishop e7 it's not necessarily that
bad his bishop on g3 isn't exactly
fantastic edem so i will probably you
know I it should still be quite okay
nothing fantastic but this somewhat
backward-looking porn on the d7 is not
such a huge deal maybe maybe 96 like
immediately preventing my bishop to move
and force me forcing me to take there
might be an option
now I have 95 as an idea which was
typically ignored so 95 fe bishop fyg
will take on this seven is there another
and I mean a different discovery I don't
think so let's do it yes 96 as well but
i don't know how dangerous that is yeah
I can take oh let's just for one moment
I have to take it right I can take I I
can take with the pawn that's the Bishop
c5 okay if it takes with the rook I have
Bishop see sex as well Bishop c6 takes
Knight takes rook t7 text a group the
age rating off to an end game ok I can
also move the night somewhere and he
takes d7 I take g2
not sure about that this looks rather
save
only wonder what about this night
against bishop endgame is this equal or
is he this is slightly better maybe
maybe why this actually slightly better
here yeah how do i play that can I march
the King up here now k let's and let's
clarify this first Jack then see what to
do about it I was thinking that King up
to fyf could be interesting he has got
three against two here with the bishop
this is something to to be concerned
about I was thinking that my king
position should give me adequate
counterplay okay
hmm that is kind of surprising that he
totally allows me to enter with the king
I understand the dangers on the
queenside but still
I can shake and Shelby should be 8r that
was a stupid stupid thing okay
ultimately it's an extra pawn hmm what
can black win that's not not clear at
all
and yeah it's not not easy at all Bishop
e3 no
hmm time morning and when I go to d5 he
would start to march the a pawn so not
sure I don't really know so not easy to
play
okay i can always take em only five and
probably draw like that the King there
will be very difficult to do something
yeah it's just a drone nothing I can do
game draw you have probably not at the
outset but it here here I should win
somehow but it turn it cut it cut turkey
somehow right c4 maybe now I don't know
this was maybe not a good idea because
he was h6e key gets to my pawns from the
back starting starting here I can
certainly improve also move like h5 for
example it's a strategically desirable
thing to play so that he cannot play G
form somewhere around here I should win
I think but this servant this was this
was giving him enough play I guess maybe
I can improve some somewhere here but
here I think the likelihood of the
drawers it's very high actually yeah it
was a strange way to play yeah he
completely ignored my mckean marching up
so it's a bit a bit hard to believe
really check
mmm computer wants to play this is
actually interesting King c5 keeping
keeping it simply on b6 I mean and only
later try to win the pawn this is an
interesting idea but I didn't didn't
have this idea at all that might be good
really the idea is just to I'm sorry
first to improve here and only later go
head capture the pawn that is an
improved version because no he does not
have a peso that might be better really
okay okay thanks for watching